thank you a warm welcome for the front
runner to be labour leader
but don't let the smiles fool you this
contest is anything but sewn up
in liverpool today the first hustings
600 labour members from the north
west their questions asked by the chair
why are you the person to beat boris
and from the current underdog a biting
swipe at the prime minister
he is in the end a liar he is callous
he doesn't care he plays at politics he
plays with people's lives he needs to be
held to account
he was the single worst foreign
secretary this country has ever seen
and i was part of exposing that i've led
a large organization i know how to make
very
difficult decisions i think i've got the
ability to bring people together
in a stronger fighting force and i've
got the utter determination
that we have to win the next general
election
but other issues from labour's recent
past also crept into the debate
anti-semitism has dogged the party in
recent years
anger and accusations about how it's
been dealt with
all five candidates have pledged tough
action and
insisted they'd voice their concerns in
the past but jess phillips challenged
the record of her rivals
the labour party needs a leader who has
spoken out against
anti-semitism and other forms of
harassment in fact
when others were keeping quiet and
somebody
who was in the room struggling for an
independent system
lots and lots of meetings i have to say
i don't remember some of the people here
being in that particular room or being
in those particular fights
today's event on the banks of the mersey
is the first of 12 that will take place
around the country in the coming weeks
liverpool is solid labour territory but
you don't have to drive
too far from here to reach one-time red
strongholds
that turn blue at the last election
whoever the next leader is will need to
reach out to these communities
if they want to return their party to
power and that's why many think that
person
shouldn't be from london does the next
leader need to be
from the north i think it's about your
principles but it certainly helps and it
certainly helps having grown up and
lived
in an area that has been affected and
has become quite angry about the
centralization
of political and financial power in
london and the south
east and on brexit a plea from another
candidate from the north west
to listen to voters my lead voting
constituents
are no more racist little englanders
than my friends who voted remain
a liberal elitist so with no obvious
winner or loser from the first event
what did the crowd make of it i thought
emily thornberry came across
very well on the day
it's obviously it's early days now i'm
still very undecided i was a bit unsure
but rebecca long bailey was fantastic
i'm gonna wait for the leadership
campaign to progress but i'll probably
be voting for lisa nandi
i think the labor party is missing a
massive opportunity i think she's the
only one that actually addresses the
fact that the second referendum policy
was disastrous i certainly wouldn't be
voting for just phillips that's
sure why um because of this disloyalty
labour members leaving with plenty to
chew on today
but with months of this contest to go
those deciding who can help the party
stand tall again
have time on their side rob powell sky
news in liverpool